walk with you is right auction bidders
pay top dollar for a series of art
masterpieces last night and what's being
called the sale of the century the
collection of David and Peggy
Rockefellers is being sold off at
Christie's here in New York it includes
paintings by Picasso Monet and other
legendary artists the three-day event
has already broken the record for the
most valuable private collection ever
sold Anthony Mason was one of the
bidders in the auction just made my
wife's blood pressure good morning the
crown jewels of the Rockefeller family
art collection went up for sale in the
first session just 44 lots but they
brought in nearly 650 million dollars
and the bidding was fevered 65 million
give me 66 the bids jumped in
multi-million dollar increments the tone
was set early when this Matisse is sold
for 80 million dollars an all-time
record for the artists to Lots later
Monet's water lilies in bloom soared
past its 50 million dollar estimate as
auctioneer you see pill cannon juggled
five bidders like a tennis game with
five racquets the bidding rallied back
and forth with increasing suspense
sixty-eight million
and kept climbing it's never too late to
jump in 71 million the final price
nearly 85 million dollars including a
buyer's commission also an all-time
record for Monet to have on the same
nice records for two of the geniuses of
painting Matisse and Monet is something
that I never imagined would happen the
Rockefeller collection maybe the most
important private collection ever sold
welcome to the annual meeting of Chase
Manhattan corporation the longtime chief
of Chase Manhattan Bank David
Rockefeller was the grandson of
America's first billionaire john d
rockefeller who made his fortune in
Standard Oil David's father built
Rockefeller Center where in a 2002
interview for Sunday morning
he gave me a tour of the family offices
belong to Gertrude Stein even here he
surrounded himself with the Masters of
modern art is collecting for you a
compulsion
it's a pleasure a pleasure David shared
with his wife Peggy says David
Rockefeller jr. who organized the sale
after his father's death last year at
101
they always agreed about an important
artwork or it didn't get bought realize
effectively a veto power the library of
the Rockefellers New York townhouse had
been home to perhaps the most coveted
masterpiece in the collection
Picasso's young girl with a flower
basket it sold last night for 115
million dollars a record for a rose
period Picasso by the end of the first
night Christie's Jessica fertig says the
auction had raised 646 million dollars
we have already broken the record for
any collection sale and the Rockefellers
collections of furniture porcelain and
American paintings are still to come as
the auction continues today and tomorrow
so still to come paintings by hopper
Sargent and George O'Keefe
sales expected to go well past
three-quarters of a billion dollars all
of the proceeds going to charity which
is amazing and it's also interesting
that so far all the winning bids were
anonymous but we have been told that
about half of them are American oh I so
love these lifestyles of the rich and
the famous stories because it's
interesting here the auctioneer would
say seventy million not too late to get
in you can spend that much magic
decision no and still having money left
over
I love his mone before he died killed 15
of his paintings slashed them said my
life is a failure I'm just gonna go
disappear obviously people still find a
value in his work thanks Anthony